you know one time I mom was fixing a fan
that was on yeah cuz I lived in the
Philippines and she was fixing the fan
cuz he was it was it wouldn't uh she was
trying to make it taller and she was
unscrewing the bottom and it came down
and she goes oh the baby Jesus Christ
gotta be careful I mean this isn't a
funny story I'm just lying on one up
your story right now my dad you don't
use your head to swipe a wasp or catch a
fan or or you don't you don't you use
your left hand to unclog ice blower a
snowboard
but yeah bad dad means the teenager
that's an idiot no he was young man Hey
Oh young he's making money he was
blowing snow he got stuck yeah well I
got it unstuck tit I could put his hand
in there and the Machine went thanks bro
Oh laughter three fingers Salvage two
but old Tricky's not there anything no
yeah you know when ads like this how old
was he like 17 a my son everytime
seniors what happened your finger every
time my dad has described every time I
have ah for the rest of his life he's
pretty cool the little nub I don't know
but but the the middle finger is it
doesn't look like knuckle and there's
just like scars around it and then the
pinky - I'm sorry to call your dad at
thumb no that's all right
blacked out in multiple martial art
should be fine so what's wrong with this
ice blower here no no leave it on crank
it up to high there's close to the blaze
that's a very good very good Peter for
shop impersonation he's not from Texas
like that sounds like a great yeah no
he's not from he's not from Dallas
you're right no but there is doubt of it
but the dumb one okay Hey Joe Hey Joe
you're a really good actor thank you I
believe that yeah herbage disposal real
quick dude that's such a good you're hey
Joe you're a good act you're a good
actor you're still breathing that's
really see you're holding right in those
wrong with the lawn mower that's a
nothing leave it on faint blood loss
there it is and then I'm the neighbor
thank you
you save his fingers no I just feel your
face right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]